voilà friot tout cela que tu y es a pris
tout cela pour l'afrique
ça promet
[Musique]
un vaccin on peut considérer que c'est
un médicament et il sert à protéger
contre un certain nombre de maladies
en principe c'est le médecin qui
prescrit les vaccinations et qu'il l'ait
fait sachant que maintenant les
infirmières peuvent également effectuer
des vaccinations vous pouvez les acheter
en pharmacie et puis il faut aussi
savoir que le service de pmi peut
procurer des vaccins pour les familles
qui n'ont pas de couverture sociale
[Musique]
offert examen clinique pour s'assurer
que l'enfant est en bonne santé qui
n'est pas fait bride
parce que pour éventuellement
contre-indiqué la vaccination et puis
une fois qu'on s'est assuré que tout est
en ordre
on fait la vaccination le ou les axes
donc aujourd'hui on va faire la
vaccination du 4ème mois ce petit bébé
vaccination votre livre terry tétanos
polio coqueluche l'haemophilus hépatite
b
voilà déjà eu sa première vaccination à
deux mois là on va faire ça deux des
quatre mois alors ce qui est important
quand on fait la vaccination c'est
d'essayer de limiter au maximum la
douleur chez l'enfant
ce qui est important pour moi c'est que
le l'enfant soit dans les bras de sa
maman c'est important parce qu'il est
rassuré sa maman peut le consoler
rapidement et ça c'est vraiment car un
point important
maintenant il faut pas pleurer du
courage pour moi c'est fini
alors comment savoir que les hauts fonds
sont bien vaccinés mais en ayant suivi
médical régulier et il faut faire tous
les examens préventifs qui sont prévues
donc là ça sera l'occasion de vacciner
les enfants on doit faire des rappels
tout simplement parce que les premières
réactions ne suffisent pas à voir une
immunité suffisante
un contre la maladie 1 et c'est pour ça
que faire un rappel permet de pérenniser
cette immunité et de s'assurer que
l'enfant est bien protégé contre la
maladie
on va refaire la prescription pour le
vaccin du cinquième mois
[Musique]
cinq mois ont fait le vaccin contre la
méningite à méningocoque de type c
encore une piqûre la prochaine fois
alors les enfants on doit les vaccinés
normalement à deux mois à quatre mois
cinq mois 11 mois 12 mois et seize mois
sachant qu' il peut y avoir des
exceptions par exemple chez les
prématurés ont fait plus de vaccins
d'accord d'où la nécessité quand même
d'avoir ce suivi médical
[Musique]
bon
alors oui il ya un certain nombre de
maladies en fait qu'ils sont apparus ou
réapparu su fait d'une insuffisance de
couverture vaccinale
on peut parler notamment de la
coqueluche est également le la rougeole
puisqu'on et plusieurs épidémies de
rougeole en france de ces dernières
années plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'enfants qui ont été atteints par cette
maladie
il ya eu plus de 6000 hospitalisation
c'est une amie qui pointait les graves
séquelles notamment neurologiques
il ya eu 15 à 20 décès c'est
inacceptable il voir un enfant mourir
d'une maladie contre laquelle il
pourrait protéger par un vaccin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on vaccine pas son enfant
non seulement on ne protège pas contre
certains noms de maladies mais on ne le
vaccinons pas vous avait pas d'immunité
de groupe c'est à dire que si vous
arrivez à vacciner un certain
pourcentage d'enfants général c'est de
l'ordre de 95% il ya secret une immunité
de groupe c'est à dire que la maladie
disparaissent naturellement
voilà donc non seulement vous ne
protégez pas votre enfant mais vous vous
protégez pas aussi les autres euros
[Musique]
chez les tout jeunes parents ceux qui
viennent d'avoir un enfant il faut
qu'ils soient impérativement vaccinés
contre la coqueluche leur vaccination
doit dater de moins de 10 ans sinon ils
peuvent attraper la couche on voit de
plus en plus de coqueluche et les
adultes et ils peuvent transmettre cette
maladie à leurs enfants qui n'est pas
encore vaccinés un don contre 0 et 2 à 3
mois 1 est la coqueluche et le tout
petit c'est na li qui peut être très
grave c'est la première cause de décès
en réanimation chez lui
propane
[Musique]